Felicity Huffman arrived at federal
court in Boston Wednesday where she and
Lori Loughlin faced a judge for their
alleged involvement in the biggest
College bribery scandal in history fans
lined up before the hearing and while
the fuller house star was all smiles
when she touched down in Boston a source
close to the actress tells et quote
Laurie is scared to death of the outcome
of the case but even more frightening
regarding the broken trust with her
children I just want them to have that
experience and get that education and
have a degree to fall back on Laurie
allegedly paid half a million dollars to
have her two daughters Olivia Jade and
Isabella recruited to USC despite not
playing sports her husband massimo jia
newly was also charged in the case they
do want them to have somewhat of a
normal you know finish out of high
school college experience maybe because
I didn't have that I wouldn't really
want that for them according to our
source Olivia claims she did not know
about the supposed deals her parents
made adding the embarrassment she has
felt in front of her peers and followers
has been a lot
Felicity and Lori are among nearly three
dozen parents charged in the cheating
scam the mail fraud charges they face
could be punishable by up to five years
in prison as for how the former
Desperate Housewives star is coping a
source close to the actress tells ET
Felicity has denied any wrongdoing to
some of her friends and just is
desperate to stay out of the public eye
Felicity's husband William H Macy was
not charged but he has been candid with
et about helping his kids get ahead one
can help your children in this business
and the nepotism works and I have no
problems with it and if I can give them
a leg up I absolutely would despite the
entire ordeal we're told loriann
Massimo's bond has remained strong a
source tells ET Laurie's main concern
after the hearing is to focus on
rebuilding her family and healing adding
but with the case and everything that
has transpired she realizes she has a
long road ahead
[Music]